You're welcome.
Well go to your mom's house. Just
seeing them come over later from Moose.
Hey Hitlers and keep them high
and tight jeans or all the way up.
You'll burn your wicked big dude. You
got to lose some more weight. Fuck,
you're doing good.
I am going on.
Yeah.
Alright,
we're back guys.
We're back.
We just had to have our moose suit. That
was, uh, that was really terrifying.
I was really scared actually.
Let's see.
What do we do this whole time without our,
without our shit drops in
her. Yeah. I don't know what
to do, mother fucker. Right.
Okay. Yeah. All right. That works.
Make sure I go retarded. That
works. And we're back. All right.
Welcome to alive.
Your mom's house and
press pause.
You're down here with all
the snowbirds and uh, Jews.
There's one and you
fucking Puerto Rican area.
There's been so many Puerto
Ricans, Cubans, Cubans.
Yeah. We couldn't go swimming today
though. Cause your water is contaminated.
Did you guys know that?
You know when you're putting me,
can you just Puerto Rican as well? This
is true. We went to the beach today. Yeah.
And they, and we went to, uh, the
guy at the hotel and we're like,
can we get an umbrella? He's like, yeah,
but you just got to let you know you
can't get in the water. I was like,
why do you think we're going
to do here, man? And I go,
why can't we get in the water? And
he goes, this bacteria is real high.
And I go, is that common? He
goes up under a few years,
have never heard of it before. I
know. And I'm like, well, okay, great.
I swam in this yesterday. I'm
sure it's fine, right? Yes. Yeah.
Just it just got here, uh, from the ocean.
Yesterday was cool, but today
is all shitty and bad. You know,
I think we're going to be radioactive now.
Terrified. This will be our last show.
Thank you,
Florida.
We flew here then know, but make
sure this is a all working though.
Hold on a second.
So just to make sure that,
okay.
That worked dirty and
disgusting. Yeah, there we go.
There we go. Okay. And
what's Your Pronoun? Okay,
so there different levels. That's fine.
Open calling me, ma'am. Left and right.
I'm very offended just because they asked
him in, you're a woman. I'm sorry bro.
Oh,
cause you're an old woman.
Well I don't, nobody calls me Sir.
They're always like little boy. Yes.
When I'm like, it's so stupid.
I hate being called Ma'am.
Someone called me madam
the other day and I really,
I liked it though cause I wasn't seven
11 buying hot Cheetos and he was like,
there you go madam. Or new words dude,
what is wrong and why
that is so offensive.
Why is it a it?
He was an idiot.
Thank you madam. Big words.
Yeah, it's a big word,
basically is a big word. And I
was so like, I felt super fancy,
you know, like okay. All right.
Shit. Cause you were a madam. Yeah.
You feel like a mistress,
like a farmhouse.
Yeah.
So many people have gone to far
mistress.com the site has crashed and and,
and they're sending messages to my
mother to be the fart mistress and she's
like, I'm not going to do it.
She's like, she's very upset,
but then she likes the flattery of the
messages. I tried to get it on Conan,
I did Conan a couple of weeks
ago and there were, you know,
they do a pre interview like
what are you want to talk about?
And you start telling them all.
And then I was like,
can we talk about foreign [inaudible]
dot com and his producer was like,
I'm listening like what is it
told him?
And he goes, he thought it was
hilarious. And then he goes,
I told Colin and then maybe
we'll get to it. And I was like,
are you fucking serious? And it goes, he,
he could go there and I go, all right.
And that was the whole time. I was just
anticipating him being like, tell me about
Fart, Mr Well Cook, can they,
they can say fart now on TBS,
right? Cause Yeah, you did the,
you know the network version, they won't
even let you no, no, no, no. Just farting.
No, no. But yeah, now
you can go full farts.
You can go all part or you are
waiting the whole time for him.
Like I was sitting there in the
chair, like, you got to do it.
And then he was like, yeah, we'll see
my guests at the fucking other place.
I was like, Oh okay. Yeah.
But I was really excited.
Do you, okay, so your mind is,
are we going to read her the emails
people have been sending a hundred
okay. Yeah. I'm excited. I
want to get her on video. Yeah,
we'll be at least at least video her
hearing them and maybe processing the
movement if you don't
know. We bought that,
we paid for the website fart mistress.com
yeah. And I told my mom like,
will you fart on this website?
And she was like 100% no. And I was
like what if we can get you money?
And she was like what kind of
money you're talking about?
And I told her like a couple
thousand dollars and she
goes, I'm not a prostitute.
And I go well what's your number?
And she goes 3000
well
cause you also position it like this
is your gambling money cause she really
likes, she loves damn ball hard cock
comes, you know in Fort Lauderdale,
Fort Lauderdale makes me laugh every time.
She loves the slots she plays,
the slots there. Play real.
It's like petty stuff, right?
Like it sucks. She's a fucking,
she's the cooler. Like she comes in,
the cooler is
when you walk in and they're like,
I wasn't going to lose. That's
the cooler right there. And,
but here's what she has advice for you.
So there's like,
it's the person measuring
the person that's like, I've
been divorced nine times,
giving you relationship advice like
that. You're like, but you suck at this.
And then she's like, I know, I know.
She's like, this machine doesn't pay.
Don't see it here. And I'm like, but if
you're saying it, it probably does pay.
So you know what's so interesting is
they put the water bucket next to me.
[inaudible]
it's like they knew that
I drink the most water.
That's some bullshit right
there. Yeah, take your time.
Yeah, you wanna you wanna
[inaudible] nipple for that.
Why are you putting the mic?
I want them to hear it.
They didn't hear that. But this is
bullshit that this doesn't dehydrate you.
Do you believe in that club?
If you think coffee doesn't dehydrate,
you psychos five Psychos,
but then I'm still thirsty when I
drink it. It doesn't do shit so hard.
Does not. Speaking of Shit,
since we've been here,
I just feel like you guys should
know that I haven't really been,
browning is much. I
know. Devastating News.
Yeah,
and I think part,
I think the problem is because we
don't have a bad day in the hotel.
We're staying.
It's disgusting affecting.
You're going to the bathroom
because my asshole is a gun shy.
It knows.
It knows that it can't relax and
release because there's no ample cleanup
provided. I have to
admit, it bums me out too.
We have bad days now in
three bathrooms at home.
I feel like was balling out of control.
You know,
you guys could get the tushy.
It's a reasonable one. It's
like 50 bucks sponsors.
It's fucking, we bought
it. They should, but yeah,
they're fucking assholes for not
sponsored. It's like 70 bucks.
It's a firehose here,
but hose,
you got to really ease into turning it
off because you can get loose with it and
it's just like,
it hurts your eyes.
It'll hurt your tender. Sweet
little asshole. And it actually,
it actually opened
up my ass home when the
water shot in there.
It actually opened it a little
and we need more brown. Yeah,
come, I've had that too. It's true. It
does that cause you'll be like, I'm done.
I'm done. Yeah. And then you go,
wow. And then you're like woo, Woo.
Like it was like somebody
got in there. Yeah, it does.
Is that what it feels like?
What,
what feels like having someone
to go in your ass feels like
go in your ass? Like what their, hey,
that hasn't happened in a long time.
It has.
That is so nasty.
Ah,
yeah.
Siri say, be honest. They don't know.
But you did used to put your
fingers in my butt. I like, because
I feel like I'm alive. Show we
can, we can say a little more.
Okay. You know, this is
going to be downloading.
I don't know why I feel more.
I'm just married to a triple d s l u t
click last late. My uh, yeah.
Okay. Can I tell you that? Honestly,
since I had our kid though and since
two holes became one, you know,
had an episiotomy. Yeah. So I'm a little
nervous cause that whole is not as as uh,
taught if you will as it
yeah.
Because I haven't noticed anything really
might be home or my vision.
Oh you're a virgin is a fucking third.
That's a loose, yeah. No,
it has to be,
you're such a liar.
So you say that sear your sweet guy and
I appreciate it. I am not being nice.
I'm being honest. I mean it does.
I have to picture like I have to picture
like eight guys standing behind me just
to try to get in there.
Like I,
I pretend it's a competition and,
and they're like, yeah, Tom. Yeah.
Like do it up, hurry up.
And then I'm like, ah.
And then there's other guys
orderly way give it to everyone.
Like it's the gardeners and it's
the fucking what we have gardeners,
so how can I get it?
Shit for the Indian guy, which is
a real thing because we have Jose,
he comes by every fucking
Wednesday. We talking about like,
all right, what does that
mean, Dal? Like wave most.
I like that.
That's giver her eggs.
Give her eggs,
eggs.
This one's fine.
I don't know what the fuck he says
honestly. Is that Daddy Yankee?
I think it is. You wouldn't
know pit bull, Huh? POSTER
MR worldwide. Do you know that dude?
He's, he's ridiculous, right? Yeah,
they are.
He makes like 35 million
easy. Right? Just like giving way was out.
What does it mean? Seriously
way. But she's not saying,
I don't know.
What is he saying?
Give her,
come
get her.
Those give her that ball juice.
It's like fill me with your guests.
So Lena,
the same thing. Yeah, always
come with those guys. Huh?
Savages. Yeah. Guys like to come.
What are you going to do this?
Isn't that crazy?
That basically every decision a
guy makes it is connected to coming
for you? Not necessarily.
Let me mean for me.
These guys are that different.
But then,
but then when guys turn like 50
they become, you know, human like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like your dad,
it became sweeter and now like when
the need to come goes down a little,
like you guys start to care about
helping turtles across the street.
I think it doesn't happen at 50 I
think you got that wrong. Maybe like 68
that's when the testosterone starts to
like dial down and you turn it into women
and you become people. It's great.
I know I have an uncle who was like,
just started crying at 75
and I'm like crying and he's like,
it's a sweet moment.
Like you were a savage dude.
Do you,
do you think your dad still comes a lot?
Definitely. No, cause he's, he has,
he's friends with a lot of older, like
older than him and he's like, you know,
my buddy, whatever, he takes a pill,
my other buddy has to inject himself.
Yeah. But he's like, you know,
this guy's 81 this guys. And I go, oh
man. Like how about you? He like, ah, no,
not a problem about like still a
lot of lead in the pencil. Not even
your old man's doing fine. I'm like
that's enough. That's enough information.
Enough information about my dad's Dick.
So I remember when I saw
his balls on the cruise,
I still think about it. Yeah. In what way?
Like how just like I remember
him flipping his leg,
her and I was like what there it is
as I recall.
I recall.
Yeah, I remember that. Crazy. Pretty big.
They're low hangers though. Like you're
going to have nuts to hang low too.
I hope so.
I can only,
I can only dream about
having balls that are,
sometimes I think about that.
Honestly not to hit it again,
but I think about it on the toilet.
Cause sometimes you're like
thinking about toilet water.
That's real to your boss
touched the water yet. No, no.
I mean I have just regular balls. They're
not. No, they are. They're really,
they're good. I really like him. Come on.
I have all the balls and
I've touched a lot of balls.
Puerto Rico. Yeah. Well,
what were they like?
Bad Ball am I mean look, one woman's
bad ball is another woman's treasure.
I don't know.
Okay.
Right. Different strokes.
Everyone's the same. So maybe
personally, here's my, I just
don't, I like him high and
tight. I do. I like, Oh yeah,
like yours are nice and high and tight.
I've had balls that are just
all skin like you're like too,
so they're too big and there's not,
there's nothing in them. It's just,
I've never,
I've been blowing old guy again.
No, they're, they're young guys at that
huge nuts, but I usually usually it,
the interesting thing Tom really thought
provoking that the bigger the balls,
I found that the shorter
and fatter the wiener,
like it would be like a coke can or the
balls. Yeah, there were shorts down.
Did it affect the loads they busted?
No,
I'm saying where the big
balls when you're like, Jesus,
this thing doesn't turn
off. Where is it? Like that.
Okay.
No, I mean, what was it like that no,
really hoppy on? Do you want
to know? Is that the most
I have the most,
a lot of loan.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah. No, no, no.
I will check off with any of you guys.
I'm serious.
This is gross, but I'm going
to do it any cause, whatever.
I mean from high school I had high school,
college girls are always like, Jesus,
what is up with all this jazz man. I
know. And I actually asked the doctor
about it once cause you know you have
like men have con like I could like it's
like a contraction, right? Like yeah, I
had, so I went to the doctor, I was like,
I was uh, I don't like 18, 19. I was like,
look man, I'm busting these huge ass nut.
Is that normal? And he was like,
what kind of con that's like,
so I described it to them in detail and he
was like, no, it's not normal. And then,
yeah, well he goes, it's,
it's, it's, it's a, you know,
high, much higher than average.
But he goes, yeah, just consider
yourself lucky. He's, he said it though,
he said it like I've been trying
to come like that for years.
I dedicated my life to this and you just
get it naturally. And I was like, yeah,
that's fascinating. I know. I wonder if
I'll and want to get into the details.
What do, do you think you have
more swimmers than most? No. No,
I don't think it has anything to do with
that. Just the amount of fluid around.
Yeah. I just have a great prostate. Wow.
I go rob.
Rob.
Wow.
Yeah, he been, did you sharpen your
knife today? Uh, you should know.
You did take a long shower. It
was really long. Yeah, I did.
Rough Rah Rah guys.
The grossest
he's soap nest. You know it's all
right. I'll get to it. Let's do this.
I have a proper show.
Open clip,
so we'll play that and then we'll get back
to this in a second. Okay. Here we go.
Forward an issues. Here we go with the
important issues of, of, of our show.
Here we go.
What I'm thinking for Marlene,
this is Mike, which is scrub kip.
Be Stuck in an elevator fixed. It's
not. That was on the phone earlier.
16 [inaudible] out.
Oh Shit.
Don't bring in one month into this.
Well,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
There it is,
right.
We are live and breath
balls, beach, Florida.
That um,
so that guy was pretty pissed off.
He's talking to an elevator
manufacturing rep on the phone.
I guess his elevator didn't get
fixed when he wanted it to, so he did
just
talking out my Beta fish.
Did he say the slut?
I didn't know that.
Nobody ever says that. Like get that
fucking slut that I was talking to.
That's so crazy. It's a tough call over
the phone to now she's a slide doesn't,
but it's a, it's a good way to provoke.
See what happens. Just spoke a little bit.
Is that slut still there? And
then they're like, excuse me.
Nobody likes that. How
can call it the, I mean,
I guess your elevator not being fixed
does piss you off. But this level,
this level,
okay. I'm sorry I have
to deal with people.
It's the worst elevator on the world.
I'm going to come in and rev
it up your fucking noses.
Get him here now.
Jesus Christ.
I,
you know what I stands out to me the most
about that is that he will shove it up.
Your noses like to be that angry
and the natural inclination to be,
I'll shove up your fucking ass.
And he was like,
stuff that fucking elevator up your nose.
It's almost like he pulled his anger in
for a moment. He didn't want to go blue.
He was like that's too far.
But it probably would hurt more
in your nose then your ass. Right.
What do you think it would hurt to have
an elevator shoved in any orifice so
that you have but yeah, your
nose. You definitely die for sure.
If I put an elevator up your
nose. Yeah. That hurts so much.
You know I keep thinking about
the animal lady this week.
Like some clips stick to me.
I keep thinking about how Lawrence rain.
Is that her name? Yeah. Oh I can show
cause it would absorb the
toxins like you would die.
And what really stood out to me about
her just laid, it gave herself a year,
an enema. Was that?
Yeah, let me bring it up.
Yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Here we go. Fucking sad.
Lawrence.
Today I'm going to do a urine for
the first time for the first time.
And you should see like,
she's like,
like I'm going to see my
dad for the first time.
She's so tough attached that
she's committing to this.
She's so skinny today.
During the day I have collected
this much.
I just
poured one court and to my
animal bucket right above me.
You pissed in a bucket is what you're
saying and you're going to put it in yet.
What happens to you
that you get that nutty?
Like how does that switch flip where
you're like, no, this is healthy.
She's a conspiracy theorist for
sure. Yeah. Yeah, she is. Cause I,
I remember one of my, uh, down here,
I went to high school in Vero beach.
If you don't know if I run
around here and what am I
friends' moms was like,
you can't trust doctors.
Like they'll, they'll fuck
with you. I'm like, okay.
And like when you're sick too,
you know, what should I be like,
I'm going to the doctor.
She was like, that's stupid.
Only an idiot would go to the doctor
and then she had all these
is alternative therapies,
which I'm sure like,
I'm not saying that there's no alternative
therapy that has, you know, value,
but if you,
if you keep embracing that
only alternative works,
then you end up putting your own pissing
it gives you are going to
die. Yeah, because who was
it? Who Was it? Who's dead?
The computer guy. Yeah. He
was alternative therapy.
He had pancreatic cancer,
which is aggressive to begin with,
is not high
chance of beating it. And they found
it early and so they were like,
we're going to take it out. And he
was like, I'm going to eat fruit.
And they're like,
yeah.
Right. What? He's like, I
fucking made these things.
I'm eating fruit. All right. I'm gonna
end. The doctor's like, all right.
He did make the shit that we're typing on.
So,
and then a few months later he was
like, oh, I fucked up. Yeah. Yeah.
That is the equivalent of like, I'm
going to get myself. You're an animal.
You're right. Gert. And it'll,
that's what happens. This lady
100% if they were like, you have a brain
tumor, we need to operate, she'd be like,
I'm going to juggle this week.
And they do see what happens.
Okay.
So I'm laying on my left side and I'm
just about to insert the hustle right now
during this process.
Okay.
She is so emotional about this.
Like she was like,
which I understand like again,
you're
putting your own piss and
shit is crazy crazy to me.
I love creating and allow the
urine to enter my colon. Oh,
I'm going to try to hold
it for about five minutes.
Girl,
you nasty as hell.
Now she's, her face is
in so much pain. Ooh,
Ooh.
Hey Marty noticing.
Okay. Yeah. What are you noticing?
So fucking crazy.
New leg again.
Okay.
I'm having a little bit
of leakage and I don't
just a little bit. I wonder if
he would have that, you know,
if you'd have that league.
I just, I don't know how people have
stuff on their butts so easily. I mean,
are you getting used to it?
You get used to it. You gotta
just some of our, I mean, I'm sure
there's people in the audience like this.
Some of our friends are like,
oh yeah, like, you know,
we bought fuck pretty
regular. And I'm like, what
maybe were the square's Tom,
you know what I mean?
Maybe we should be giving ourselves p
animas and fingering are two different
things though. Right? But fucking
regularly and giving yourself a piano bar,
but all you have to,
I mean,
shouldn't you give yourself an enema
before you have bud Saks? Yeah. Yeah.
Or a strong performers do that.
It's a very strong performance
as a courtesy, I'm assuming. I
think it's a courtesy to yourself,
man. Makes it easier as
wild. Cool. One more time.
Whoa.
Oh.
This purple vision.
She's tripping out
purple vision toxins in her bloodstream.
Crazy.
10,000 more people coming together
and support support me.
It sounds like Trump at a Trump
rally or something. Right?
Like maybe that's why he has
such a big ego. He's like,
I'm putting pissing my ass every night.
People love me. I can't say I
can't help it. Facebook live of it.
Yeah. And support. God, I can't watch me.
See she's saying her own name now.
Lauren. That's what's going on.
Who Sell Marketing the clamp again?
Oh boy.
Wow. Close the, Oh my goodness.
I almost want to cry. So do, I
don't want to watch and do this.
It's tough.
I can't do it anymore.
And my botox reason region,
it might just be because the,
the urine is a little bit called that.
That's not the only reason you're feeling
that way. Let's move right along Tom.
Yeah. Interesting enough. Okay.
You brought her up or I feel bad.
She's crazier.
Crazier than catch it. Okay. So what
I learned about you on this trip,
it's very interesting.
After 12 years of knowing you,
I feel like I know almost
everything now you are anorexic,
you can use,
I can use either hand.
And,
and
what's neat about that talent is that
sometimes I notice you sign with your left
and it looks all retarded.
Like you'll be all, wait, what?
He looks stupid when you do it.
But it's cute. Like you saw it,
it looked stupid because it's not right.
Like you shouldn't just like
when you sign your name,
but it got me to thinking what do
you do with either hand, which,
which hand do you wipe with?
Cause I'm not with you at those times.
Very thought provoking. I mean all
the things it's like, it's automatic.
Like I'm just good at
everything but I do it
like the hand chooses like through
the anorexia chooses itself.
So I write lefthanded and it looks stupid.
I brushed my teeth lefthanded
eat with a fork left,
I throw a ball right handed,
didn't notice that. And I,
I prefer to jerk it right handed.
I can do it with the other hand.
Okay.
But I prefer especially to finish
with the right hand, you know,
there's just like, there's
just, I know how to,
yeah
though that your, your subtle moves
and especially for like that finishing,
you know what I mean? Rounding
third, I like to go back to them.
Like I can go left, left, left wing
up and then it goes to the right hand,
you know? So I do that and I
definitely wipe right handed.
Yeah. Interesting. I think higher
skill level things are right handed.
Wait a minute,
but you write with your left.
That's quite possibly the highest skill.
Yeah.
Throw a football man right handed.
Okay. Yeah. Interesting. In baseball,
I shoot right handed.
Yeah. Golf, right handed.
Not that I do that regularly.
But you're not a golfer.
I didn't know all this about
you. These are all new things.
Yeah, I didn't know it.
I like learning.
We should go out to dinner sometime.
Tell you a bunch of stuff if you want to,
if you want to find out.
I've also been watching you do
everything right handed everything.
I have known you. This is
useless. Why don't you donate it?
Why don't you give away?
Even when I do polities and stuff,
the left side is terrible.
It's wonky. It's weaker.
I'm totally right dominant,
you know? Yes. This talent,
it's just being strong and stuff.
Okay. But back to you. So
notice this week we spent a lot of time
together. We've been on vacation here. Uh,
you really savor your body functions
like more than anybody I know.
Like you'll sneeze,
like you do this annoying thing where
you sneeze like three times in a row.
Like it's clearly for attention.
But yeah,
third time
you have to look at the light
to get it out. That's the worst.
I always look for the light.
Oh yeah.
And if you say bless you before I sneeze,
I'll knock you the fuck.
Yeah,
because it will fuck with me.
It makes me so upset when you're like on
the edge like hot and someone was like
bless you, bye. Fuck you. Fuck
you. I don't know. It goes away.
Yeah. Cause you need, you need total
focus. Like when I see you doing your,
that doesn't,
I don't feel like that's what I look like.
I have to stop and let you dig your
retarded face and then you sneezing threes
and then after it you'll be like,
oh that was such good snakes.
I like how it feels.
Don't you like that feeling now?
It's a little, it's a little pleasure.
It's not like, I'm not saying it's a myth.
If you have like a like three or more in
a row and you have that momentary buzz
from it, you're like, whoa. It feels good.
I like it like that.
You'll be like,
that was a good cough or that was a
good shit or that was such a good shit.
Like I don't really enjoy shooting.
I just like,
and I'm like, Oh God, I feel
so fucking good right now.
And she's like this golf
thing. Like I'll, I'll
cue tips. Look like someone
dip them in orange paint.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. Yeah, we got a
lot of waxes. Hereditary. Yeah,
that's what my dad told me. I know.
It was like, I was like, oh dude,
I had a lot of wax. He's
like, yes. Genetic, like all
excited. I'm like, couldn't,
it couldn't be a vertical leap
ahead to be fucking ear wax. Sweet.
It's just really cool jeans.
You got that down.
Yeah, but you do like them more
than anyone else. It's true.
All right. Do you want to go back to this
or no, this isn't, what's the, was this?
No, he don't like that.
Next to the better guy.
All right. We're done with
elevator guy. The fucking lady
ended it. So Christina, it says, I was
listening to episode Oh nine this morning.
No, was an audio issue. Uh,
three 36 in awful sound filled
my headphones and it's you,
you sneezing. It says, let's see.
[inaudible]
you have the fucking
balls to talk about my
the fuck man.
But that was so charming.
It was like a little like a little dose.
That's hideous.
Maybe that's why I don't enjoy them.
Oh Man. I'm going to set it affected me
emotionally and still have not recovered.
Also also at 1508,
there was a sound of what I think was it
touched individual attempting to sing.
It was deeply disturbing and hope it
was just an equipment issue that can be
fixed. And then it says, click
here to hear it. Here's this one.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wow.
By the way, that's called a
perfect impression. I don't know.
Yeah. I'm a huge DNR fan, guys.
Okay.
Ah, you can't take your
headphones off now, can you?
Yeah.
You are fucked now. You guys
are all rotten. All of you.
You're terrible. You're the
worst. Don't do it again. So No,
don't do it again. Don't do it again.
No, don't do boring things. Okay. Okay.
All right guys. Let's get to some
why a major business. First of all,
we know a lot of people been writing in
about this very important debate that's
been raging on in the your
mom's house community,
and that is whether or not
shit's pushed the fart out.
Wow.
Yeah. Very divisive. Finally,
someone is addressing,
so
this came in from Zachary? Yeah. Hey,
Hitler's. I've been thinking about Europe.
I know.
It's so funny.
God dammit.
Hitler's every,
every one of them starts
hailing. Okay. Hang on. Learners.
I'd been thinking about your far
and shit situation. Any rights.
Honestly,
I'm deeply offended.
Who are we to apply socially
constructed roles to shits and farts.
Maybe some farts push out shits
and some shits. Bush out farts.
You excrement. Normative.
Binary Standard. Yeah.
Should be cast aside and we should just
accept that. Farts and shits are fluid.
Anyway,
I hope.
I hope you can get rid of yours says
normative constructs and see the light.
Keep it high and tight. Thank
you Zach. Well, thank you. Wow.
That's a really
good stuff.
Yeah. Well that's really
interesting. Well,
did you want to read something,
Tommy? Yeah. Which one? The
next one. Well, no. Yeah,
on this topic I'm saying, well, a
good job. Young Jedi.
That was, that was great.
I mean, no, once a listener
brought it to my attention,
I was totally blown away.
Yeah. You had me believing far.
It's supposed to shit out for years.
That's what my mother taught me.
That's not true because they're
taught me if farts push the shit out.
Yeah.
When shit was done,
there'd be so many parts after it a
shit out when shit was out there before.
It's not necessarily so Tom
Shit's Bush the farts out. Right.
So then there should be four. It's at the
end of the shit is what you're saying.
If our sports the shit out,
but we're going the other way on it.
You want to even understand this.
This is high level stuff.
Philosophically speaking. Well, I had an,
I had an epiphany on this very topic, uh,
as we've been spending
time here in Palm Beach,
is that I farted the other day and I
kept farting and farting and farting and
farting with no shit. Okay.
And I thought to myself,
I thought to myself,
can't we have farts for
the sake of having them?
Why? Oh yeah.
Why must all farts have
purpose or utility? Oh,
he wouldn't really philosophical.
Thank you. Yeah. I mean,
it's like this capitalistic notion that
everything has to have a fucking utility
attached to it. You really did. What a
farts or just refer to sake, like art
first static enjoyment.
There's no usefulness to them.
Yeah. You're opening my whole mind up
again and again. Really interesting stuff.
I thought it was super
deep, Bro. Thanks guys.
Um, here's a, a thought
provoker it's also fowl.
Uh, it says sub cane. I was sitting in bed
after a night at the bars and
my girlfriend was vomiting
in the bathroom right
next to my bedroom after one
too many adult beverages. Nope.
That's when something amazing happened
at the same moment while she barfed it
made a sound. Only Chris Jeans
I could love. She farted,
which raises the question,
what do you call it when you
puke and Fart at the same time?
Keep it high and tight and Paulien
by sincerely hot cocoa. Whoa.
Hmm.
What? Do you have a name for
that? No, that is a thought.
Provoker then you can fart,
puke and Fart.
I feel like those two go hand in hand
because you can't have food poisoning.
Yeah. And if you barf and
Fart, it could be a bart.
I guess I would just call it a
Bert and leave it at that. Yeah,
yeah. Well done, Tom.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you're right. Let's leave it at
that. Yeah. Here's another thought.
Provoker that came in. I really like
this one. Okay. Are you ready? You guys,
this is from Gerald. Uh, he writes,
can retarded people vote?
Whoa.
That's such a good question.
It's mean,
and you go like, come on. But then
like a few seconds later, you're like,
that's a good question.
Like, right, right, right.
The answer's yes. Wait, how do you know?
Wait, wait, what about
retiring people voting?
He was voting. Yeah, cause they
can't be like, dude, not you.
Thank you. Can you go to vote? And
they're like, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no. You're like, I can't. No,
that's true.
Someone helped him sign. Well now wait
a minute, that's a physical disability.
But he was mentally disabled
as well. Okay. Yeah. But
what if he's like, you know,
you know.
Okay.
Like what have you seen
when you were like, this guy
doesn't know what day it is.
You know,
like
I'm serious.
Like can that guy,
he cannot, how do you
know this though? What?
Oh,
you retarded.
Interesting. And uh, I wonder, I
wonder, couldn't can retard it.
They can drive clearly can.
Yes they can. We learned that as long
as you can pass the driving test,
you can show up fucking drooling and
no, it's true. And if you pass the test,
they were like, you passed the test
like, but I'm saying for voting,
it's your, it's your constitutional
right. You're 18. That's true. American.
That's the only two prerequisites.
I think you would have to be
just beyond like they literally,
they would have to be like, no,
you know, like he was like, ah,
like if you can't find your
way in the booth, then baby,
they can go like you definitely camp.
Oh, but so wild. If you're like,
I like orange.
What?
That's not crazy.
I'm an actor.
I'm so offended. Blah,
blah, blah, blah. Says,
okay, do top dogs. I'd go retarded.
Oh yeah. That's my favorite.
Where is that? Oh yeah. I
go retarded. I go retarded.
Yeah, I got retarded. Yeah,
it's the best. All right. As I
read this one, this is another thought.
Provoker. Let's see this one. Yeah.
Okay. Hi Hillary. God Damn it.
They're all, it's a lot. It's a lot.
Do you guys think deaf people are more
grossed out by Farge than non deaf people?
That's a good question though.
I look at it like this.
There are other senses are
heightened just like blind people,
including the smells, but add into the
mix. They can't hear them. A silent,
but deadly is always worse because
it sneaks up on you. Basically.
Their whole life is nothing but silent.
But then
that's from Kevin. Kevin,
you're a Goddamn road scholar.
And that is true because
every time someone could,
it could be like super loud and you'd
be like, what the fuck man? Yeah.
Well they just kick you. It's the
warning so you can brace. Right.
So when you know the expectation is met,
then you know that's true. Yeah. You're,
you're, you're, you're, it's always a
surprise. Yeah. Let's talk about death. So
Jerry Lewis died. Yes. He was, uh, uh,
Christina's. Yeah. Not a fan.
He was,
while
speaking of retarded, that was
his whole thing. That is true.
His whole thing was acting
retarded. Um, funny,
retarded big teeth and the
big glasses. Yeah. Yeah. He,
he basically locked down
retarded. Um, I mean, that is,
that is,
ah,
that's Jerry Lewis.
If you didn't,
and he died and they did this thing,
the Hollywood reporter,
which is, it's really big in,
in La that the trades, right?
Like the industry news and Hollywood
reporter is definitely one of the biggest,
they did a special interview where they
were interviewing people that are still
working in Hollywood over 90 years
old and cause this just to be like,
well that's what they wanted to know.
They're like,
why are you doing stop and just relax.
But I mean they were also celebrating
them, you know, they're like,
you're old as fuck and you're still
entertaining people and it's pretty,
you know, it was probably a, it's a cool
thing. The Hollywood reporter calls you,
you work in Hollywood, it's a
big deal. They go to his house,
he allows them into his house.
They set up for eight an interview that's
going to be in print but also it to
air online.
And he was such a deck and it's,
it's Kinda hilarious. But like
he just was like, it's like,
why would you even say yes to the
interview? That's a thing is that he had,
he was a notorious, they don't
just show up. They weren't like,
you want to do an interview
now, you know? No.
And he had a bad reputation for being
really grumpy towards the end of his life.
Yeah. This is pretty
funny. This is pretty,
we're doing a feature on people who
are still working in their nineties.
Have you ever thought about retiring?
Why
was there never a moment that you
thought it might be time to retire or you
would want? Why? Yeah,
so that the management being the
interview, I'd be like, Oh my God,
you come from,
you come from a generation,
a little older and I think of Bob Hope.
George Burns.
I liked it. He tells a 91 year old guy.
You come from a generation a little older.
Yeah, no shit. Huh?
People you knew, many of whom
didn't want to, uh, were,
are never retired either. Um, do you
see similarities with them? None.
None.
What do you think drives people like
you and to want to keep working?
Cause we do it well.
Shit. Wait, this is even better.
This, this is great. Hold on. Hold on.
What's different about performing
now for you than say 20 years ago?
How has it,
how is it different for you?
What an inspiring interview,
Huh? Hey, here's another lab.
Have you made any, do you, how do you
keep the material fresh sessions to be,
you know, older and you're in,
you're performing or does it?
How do you keep the material fresh
for yourself by working at it?
So then if you're this guy, you're
like, oh my God. So then he goes like,
cause you're out. You're basically
willing him to just talk more,
not give you one word answer.
So he's like,
well here's one I know factually you'll
have to give me a different answer.
He's asked, he's gas. How is
Vegas different now than when
you started working there?
50 plus years ago, right?
1 million. Which is
Vegas different. Totally different.
You then when you first came here,
what was the first time you you
performed at Vegas? 1947 sorry,
seven times. What? What face? She's
like when you first showed up. It's not,
it's the same.
Exactly the same.
It's totally that.
There were two hotels.
You Lying Dick,
he,
he's so dismissive.
Why do the interview if you're
not even going to answer the guy?
It's so weird.
Well, it looks like, is it about being, I
wish she could see that. What is it about,
how would you describe the place?
It doesn't need to be
sharp in 1947 what was it?
I wasn't a little bit of a dusty
cow town. It was, what was it?
What was it like Dustin cow town.
Well, thanks for the
interview, Jerry. Yeah.
Here's the super cut of his answer.
Why?
Why none?
Cause we do it well is not at all.
Why working at it? Anyone
that's $90. No, no.
1947 it's not,
it's the same.
Exactly the same Dustin cow town. No, no,
you asshole total. I have to admit, I
think that's the funniest shit he's ever.
Absolutely.
I feel like at 91 I would give
the same interview, you know?
Well that's the thing is once your
face starts melting off of your skull,
you know what I mean?
Like you,
that's when you go behind closed doors
and just retire. Yeah. You know, just,
just give it up. Your Ego and the guy
is such a fucking egocentric. Yeah.
Torturing people with your existence.
At that point. You know what I mean?
Just go away and die like the
rest of us. Oh my God. Sorry.
Is that too dark?
It's too old.
How do you know where blue jeans
came from? You know about this?
During the 1950s young America discovered
blue jeans and the industry exploded
in the United States.
It's a hidden appeal club.
I had you looking over here.
Boom.
Okay.
Do you know
the fucking hurt?
That was mean.
That really hurt actually.
You're the Jerry Lewis.
That was a dry heave.
God, you're terrible. All
right. Here's another thought.
Provoker so there's no more barf clubs.
When food goes right through you,
is it the meal you just ate or
a prior one being pushed out?
Good question. I don't see how it could
be the meal you just ate. It can't be,
but it feels like it does,
but maybe it's pushing the bad food out
that you had earlier and that's what's
cleaning you out, right? The
Prius, the meal that was,
I mean,
you're getting into medical stuff now.
It's making space.
Wow.
That's what it is.
Yesterdays
stomach's like fucking get out of here.
You also knew the retarded question town.
If I can an expert of West Palm Beach.
Huh?
Do you want to do a master of accents?
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Totally. Okay,
so this came in. Let's see
what this is here. This is a,
I have like a fucking God damn nat.
Alright,
so this is Scottish.
Woof Blatz a toughie.
This couple is on the Jeremy Kyle show
confronting each other about cheating.
Oh, all right. Let's see if
you guys can figure out what's
yeah,
that was English.
Just so you know.
No,
I heard
it's not,
I know what you thought it was.
Good n word. No, no, no, no. It
sounds like it. I heard big words too.
I heard you know what? Yeah.
And she said it's clear.
She said it's clear.
Yeah,
it was clear something
obviously she said
obviously. Oh honestly, okay.
Fucking show offs and then,
and then
mine I think.
Okay.
So let's go back to the one where
everyone thought they heard something.
Cause I have, I have the clip here.
Okay. You have a, exactly. Okay.
Let's hear it one more
time and then, okay, here
we go. Okay, here we go.
And Go ahead.
Losses.
That's good.
Blank or conversation.
Okay,
good. So that by the way, that the
beginning is, she's saying you did.
She's saying you did.
That's how heavy the Scottish accidents.
That's you did.
And then,
Oh man,
good.
She's saying the n word conversation.
So now you're going to say,
see when you finally get
the balls to admit it,
you're going to say one or two lassies.
That's what the whole thing.
That's what she says. I
swear to you. Yes it is.
She's racist.
Two losses. I heard. That's what she says.
Well, the philosophy here, Scottish,
do you not think she's saying that
you think the translation is wrong?
She says the n word conversation
with no, she doesn't. No, I know.
I'm sure the translation is accurate.
I just don't, you know that's crazy.
That's crazy that that is English.
Maths, English. Damn, that is,
that is English when I,
okay.
He says when I slept with someone else,
he does.
He says, when I slept with someone
else, I told her when she did it,
she lied for a year and a half.
That's what that's right here.
When I slept Sunday,
we'll talk to her.
These are our fucking
brothers and sisters guys.
Yup.
All right. That was a horrific
failure. That was bad. All right.
You know what I've been
noticing on this vacay?
Daddy is vacation dads.
They at the poppy, sorry, I'm in Florida.
There is a specific,
there is a specific type of vacation.
Dad, I've been seeing where they,
they're always shirtless, right in
their boxer, whatever. Swim trunks,
and then they have the hard booze belly.
There's that guy, but then dad bod, right.
It's hard,
but then I saw they had like a rib,
the rib cage shows and the fat belly,
which I feel like it should be either or,
but not both. It's a good observation.
How do you have a fat
belly and the rib cage? She
Stage three cancer. Actually. No, that's,
that's totality. That man,
the eclipse.
Ah.
Oh my God.
Prominences how many of you did that
guy's voice during the lifestyle?
It was great. Right. We
did it the whole time.
He was so excited.
Yeah,
that was great. That's love that
they do that dad prominence is uh,
that's hard to achieve that you got
to go hard for years to get that,
that special bar bod for where
the ribs and the big hard hoochie.
That's rough man.
You got to like really booze it up.
Definitely six days a week and and
like you still somehow stay active
so you have the hard gut and you're like,
I'm doing all right.
I've got the ribs on the side.
It's a Florida bought,
it's a Florida guy bought
totally.
What I've noticed is on every
beach, whether it's, you know,
it's like a Florida keys bod,
but I noticed like in
south beach or are here,
there's always the guy who looks
like a piece of fucking beef Jerky,
skinny,
skinny guy with his dog ribs
showing leather skin like
charcoal king's son. More and more,
more, more, more, more, more. Yeah. Yeah.
That is a Florida guy to Florida guy.
But then they're, they're,
they're athletic. Like they
run all day or something.
You're like, what are you
doing? You just want to die,
like you're trying to kill yourself,
the sun worshipers, man. You
know what else is a stupid,
so you see it in the south, you
were pointing out, you're like,
look how this dip shit is dressed.
See,
I'm used to seeing this
from growing up here,
but so we're at the hotel
and this guy has on like,
like pink khaki style,
you know,
like pink shorts with a belt and then a
tucked in shirt, buttoned down collar.
Like he looks like a, like a
Frat, like going to the game.
It's a Douche bag. And she's like, what
the fuck is that guy wearing? And I go,
Oh yeah, that's a def. That's like a,
it's like the southern preppy look,
you know what I mean? And, and I got,
yeah, I hate him so much too. Uh,
and she's like, who dresses like that?
I'm like, like 18 million people. Uh,
well, because like, because seriously
in La, if I saw fucking dude,
we're in like pink, pink, khaki
shorts, a brown braided belt,
and then like a polo
taller and then tan top siders with
no socks. I know you'd be like,
this dude's about to get beat.
That motherfucker will be dead.
There's no way you would survive.
But it's like automatic, right?
You see that guy doesn't even,
you don't even blink when you see that
guy and you're like, fuck that guy.
But you know,
he's like a preppy douchebag.
Douchebag. It's a Douche bag at
the Brooks brothers. Look. Yeah.
Fuck the Brooks brothers. You're going
to like the way you look at that. Them
No,
that's men's warehouse.
You're gonna like the way
you look at Brooks brothers.
Well, what's Brooks? Brian say? I
love how much you don't know that,
but I have no capacity for,
you know,
I don't fucking care that Brooks brother.
That is some southern shit though.
We don't have that in la. No fucking
way. When a guy wear like a lime Tuxedo,
why does that cause seersucker suit
to fucking super southern. Yeah.
That's never been like
Georgia, Alabama. Yeah. Yeah.
The Carolinas nerds racist
places, right? Yeah. It's like,
it's, it's an Alpha that says, now I
might be racist. Right. The plantation.
Yeah. You get the suit, you get the
Tiki torch. You're ready to go now.
Got The whole outfit, man. Tiki torch.
Alright. Half those guys were prepped out.
They were like wearing collared shirts.
They went to Brooks brothers. They did.
And they're like, I liked the
way I look. I want to go out.
Uh, you're smart, but all cells are fine.
Should we do ours?
Our specialists also,
you want to get that twin thing came in.
We've been really asking great
questions about twin. Yeah.
And are there any twins here? No. Twins.
It's like almost 500 people. Uh, sorry.
Like you represent the
twins that aren't here.
They didn't want to come this,
these guys are actually twins
and they're talking about it.
They couldn't get inside. She was too
tight. Yeah. And so you stepped in,
took a smaller pieces that way you get it.
Another girl,
I did not understand that. Their Twitter
accents are a fucking, oh no, no, no,
they're twins. So, but the, here's what
the guy says, this is what he gets to.
So there's, there's this lady's
interviewing these two twins.
One of them basically says that, you
know, a guy had trouble with the girl.
She was with and then,
okay. It was, they were friends. I thought
it was like you couldn't fit inside.
So he called you in because you have a
narrower penis. And he was like, okay,
we got everything. Just the same, same,
everything is identical. Everything is
identical. So that's another eyebrows.
A case that are dicks are the same.
Exactly the same.
I'm beginning to lean towards that
as the solution to this a thought.
Provoker yeah, yeah,
yeah. I mean it's, it's
should ABC is going to do a profile
next week. All right. There. All right,
let's do some, uh, do you want to, do you
fill her up? Yeah, sure. All right. Okay.
Let's do we need our
scene? Okay, here we go
too.
I like the ceremony.
Roller skating, you know.
Okay.
So for filler up sealers
shot we're doing today, hey,
your mom's house,
addition of filler up sealer shot,
meaning
that we're going to discuss people
that have been featured on the show.
So first, first we have the ladies. Okay.
So would you rather fill up
and seal shut rain Florence
today. Okay. Today during the day.
I have collected my urine in
this. We know her now. Okay,
so you, you know who
that is? She's so crazy.
Or would you rather fill up and sail?
Shot,
calm down?
I think we've spoken.
The tribe is spoken,
but if I have to choose, I mean I cannot
really think about it. They know I am.
I am. Here's a rain, Florence.
She's going to be all weird and oh,
she's going to cry.
Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
She is filled up with pis,
so
I feel like the moose soup lady is a real
pig and the sense of it like she is a
savage. Yeah. Yeah. Like rain's going to
be like, I want you to connect with me.
I don't want to connect. Yeah. She's going
to cry and feelings and all that shit.
I'm ready to make love.
No, I don't want that.
And Moose Soup lady is going to be like,
fucking just slam it in there.
Don't give a shit.
Yeah.
Moose Soup Lady would take your head and
just force it in between her legs. Yup.
Calm down layer for myself.
And you'd have to,
you'd have to eat her box so
she won't let you out. Oh Gee.
Eat all her moose suit
before you get out of that.
Oh Man,
I'm going to go,
I bet at least if you were eating her out
she'd be super complimentary, you know.
Musu you guys are doing good.
Yeah.
She'd be so much fun. I feel like
the moose soup ladies a party. Yeah.
And rain is like a serious bummer. It'd
be a downer. Yeah. I'm, I'm almost,
yeah, it actually depends what mood you're
in. If you want to get fucking wild,
you go
move soup all the way. If you want
to like really take your, yeah,
if you want to have like
an emotional connection,
then you rain is like the end
my button now. You know and
just depends what you like.
Let's ask the audience who here would
rather make sweet love multiple times to
reign Florence, the urine therapy lady and
who would take the moose soup lady?
You guys are fucking pigs.
You guys are doing good.
All right.
Holy Shit.
Okay,
so now we have this other one.
Get my show now it's the men, because
I'm definitely, I'm with them.
I'm going Moose suit. I'm just going
to fucking party. Yeah, because also,
you know she drinks you just like,
just give me a handle of whiskey and I'll
fucking do it. You just get through it.
She's a serious pig.
Okay,
so here are your guys. Okay. Oh boy.
Somebody was like, Eh, it's guys that
have been featured on this podcast,
so it's not going to be good.
So would you rather fuck,
would you,
would you rather have be filled
up and sealed shut by this man
rock
who is a master of sharpening his sword
50 times,
50 times?
Or would you rather
have sex with this man?
Oh,
the story.
It's not going to be, I mean,
close your eyes. Close your eyes.
Close your eyes. Close your
eyes. All right, so there's
kisses, kisses on your neck
and then
Oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh.
He makes that noise
from a fucking highway.
Imagine if he's up inside of you
just pumping over and over.
The Rab Rab guy is so fucking creepy.
I can't even,
I'm so not in.
He's a master of lovemaking.
You I that doesn't,
but doesn't matter.
Here's why I don't like him. He'll
take longer because he's mastered his,
his circumstances. Right. Circumscription
how'd you say that's
all beside the testicle?
We found
old videos of him. Yeah. I just
want to see this like, I don't know,
30 plus years old still.
He was talking about your deck
and your balls then like he is,
he hasn't wavered at all man. When you
finish the kidney massada testicle.
Okay.
How's it called?
East in crowd about factory
producing a lot of sexual energy.
This is from the 70s yeah. Okay. Went
back to the story. Okay. Rob. Rob.
Yeah.
I mean it's a really
interesting one to think about.
So you have a guy who for 50 years,
he's just been like touching his dick,
talking about his dick,
talking about sex.
So maybe it'd be like the most
mind blowing sexual experience.
You could ever know why he's
such an expert. So sharp.
I mean woman to woman,
like the,
all these scenarios are about getting
in and getting out. Right. So mine.
It's like I'm going to get in there and
I'm going to let the Trans Canada Dad,
he's going to be so stoked. Dude. He's
never had a mouth on his penis ever.
This'll be the first time any woman's
ever tagged is nuts and he's going to love
it and I'm going to make this guy's life
dude,
the Transcanada highway.
That's how you see it to get in.
Get it out.
But what about,
that's the thing in this scenario,
what's supposed to be happening is these
guys are going to town for like hours,
so you can't really think
of it as in and out. Yeah.
Maybe she's got a good
point. Wait, hold on.
The lady in the front just said the rub
rub guy is going to be counting out like
one.
Great.
So you're going to have
to hear this asshole count
that was racist the way you did.
Wow.
I was doing an impression.
So yeah, that's how it is.
50 time and then he'll go 50
times, 50 times, you know,
turn in tunnel.
That guy's awesome.
Yeah.
But as a woman you can just close your
eyes and like let him get excited.
But let me propose this to you,
sir. Go ahead. Your scenario,
what you're saying makes sense. If you're
like, the idea is to get in and out,
but what if in this scenario
that we're proposing, yeah,
you have to spend an hour with the person.
She would you rather have
the Rob Rob Guy who's like,
I make you cum fast hot,
or
okay,
it's true.
Canada. Whoa. Oh,
that guy
our, yes. You know why? Because I'll
give him a thimble full of whiskey,
which he's never had in his life
and he'll go crazy. He's like,
this is cool and it'll be,
it'll be so much fun for him.
I would do it for him.
Oh,
the story that this road towels.
Aye.
I would fuck the rob rob course.
Dude,
that guy's going to open your mind up.
You'd be like,
I've never even felt that in my
balls before. And He'd be like,
I know I'm a fucking, I'm the master
of this rob, Rob Guy. I'm the rub rub.
All right, let's take a poll. Who here
is going to go for the rub? Rub Guide?
Yes. A hundred percent okay. Okay.
And what about the Trans Canada highway?
Give me my role.
Oh yeah.
Thank you. Where's that
from? Give me my real word.
Give me my reward of porn to come.
The cubs,
that's the old was really gross.
I want to see all the cum on my face.
I can
make sure. I don't know
a lot. Okay, so Steve,
it's very Donald.
Pretty Long.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Was there anything else I want to do
it. Would you rather see? Oh, okay.
Okay.
Would you rather it's,
let me see what I have to pee so bad.
Hopefully you guys don't have to pay.
Drink
the top layer.
Did she ask
John
or sex with your sister?
They give a face.
Grandmother walks on you masturbating.
Never have another orgasm.
Fine.
The play is trying to play with.
All right.
I'll say this before we get started with,
would you rather you have a
gift for these? You really do.
You've come up with some of the best ones
ever. They come out of you like that.
It's amazing. Yeah. It's
because I understand suffering
and no, I feel like I,
I feel like I like what is misery?
The would you rather choose really good.
Thank you. No thank guys. Please, let's
go. Okay. Okay. What'd you rather?
Yeah, I like, what'd you
rather wear? A fart helmet.
What's a fart helmet?
It's my own design.
So a fart helmet is,
it's a tube that's hooked up to your
butthole and then it's connected to like a
space helmet. Like what?
You were like a mask? Yeah,
so far mass. Oh, they did?
Okay. So, but every Fart,
it's in your face and
you're smelling it all day.
Do you smelling your own farts all day,
all day or,
or you pee in a mason jar,
but you carry it with you
everywhere and you're like,
you have to do, you have to
talk about it. Talk about it.
Like I know some giant, you meet
people, you're like, this is my urine.
Hi.
Believe in keeping all of it.
I can get you a jar if you would like and
introduce you to the lifestyle or just
smell your own farm with a mask
on. Right. Do you realize that?
Like as crazy as you look
to people when you're like,
this is my urine.
Uh,
if you walk into the bank with
your fart mask on, it's just,
they're pressing the button under the
desk immediately. Right, right. Well that,
that's what I'm saying is that
either scenario is a life ruiner. No,
they definitely ruin your life. You're
kind of, you come up with these.
I just think about what will be the
most horrible shit in the world. Yeah.
Like a fart helmet. It's
gonna it's a mask, right?
It's hard to perform.
It's hard to carve.
The performs your standup career is over.
Like you can't call the club,
make sure you have the mic inside my mask.
So I don't miss any farts
while I'm up there. No,
they won't. They won't hook
you up with that. Yeah,
but you could put your
urine mason jar down.
Well then that disqualifies
you from a lot,
like imagine having to do
Conan and then you're like,
and he's like, what's that tongue?
And then I tell him and he's like,
we'll be right back. Well, interesting.
You should ask. Yeah. Starred, urinated
on his Mason Jar. Yeah, that's a thing.
Your life is ruined. It's pretty awful,
but I still think you have some chance,
you know, like some people
would not notice your mason jar.
Some people will be like, okay, and kind
of, you know what I mean? Kind of move on,
move on.
I think you have to go mason jar.
A fart mask is 100% you got it.
You should have tin foil on your
head too. Like you. You can't,
no one's going to talk to you. I
call it a fart. Hell, you say helmet,
but you're describing a mess. It's
over your, your face is concealed.
And then when people were like, are you
scared about the apocalypse? You know,
or how I have a fart tube going from
the my ass to my mouth and they're like,
I'll see you later.
And I always walk away.
So hundred percent mason jar.
Yeah. I'll take the mason
jar too. It's apple. Exactly.
You have a story and then they're like,
can I have some of
the essence of it is you have
to tell people like, I've
decided to do this thing.
I collect my urine. That's
the craziness, and then I go,
have you ever read a urine enema
and then they're like, you have to,
you have to preach the gospel or the
exit over there if you don't mind.
All right. What are you
going? I'm going to take a,
I'm going to take the
mason jar to mason jar.
Clap for a Mason Mason jar?
Yeah.
Fart helmet.
Wow.
There's some nasty ass girls in the crowd.
How could you what?
You like your own brand,
but your job is over.
There's no way your boss is like,
it's cool. You worked from home.
Do you have,
are you in a relationship?
You're married?
Are you single?
What?
Yeah, it's a, yeah, that
could be a career. If you're
like, I wear my part mask.
You could incorporate this into
your website and now you're here,
you're making even more money.
You just said that so sincerely.
Well, now I'm thinking like she's
thinking you're working from home now.
You've got fart helmet,
mistress.com.
It's fucking brilliant, dude. It
becomes a lifestyle. It's a brand. Okay.
All right, moving along. Here's
my second one. Okay. Okay.
Okay.
Would you rather,
would you rather be Vegan,
but you're one of those vegans that you
have to fucking talk about it. 24 seven.
I want it to be respectful.
I'm sure there's a few litter,
not proselytizers, but you're
the annoying kind. Okay.
And you're constantly proselytizing.
Every time someone is with you,
like a hobo shoes are leather and
rice and you talk about
your smoothies all the time.
I like bees are,
are uh,
suffering when you eat honey
and you're like, yeah, yeah,
you're one of those annoying people
who doesn't eat anything on the menu.
So when we go out, you're always like,
is there dairy in at that lactose
freeze that gluten free is a,
so like all you can eat is like five
things and you're a pain in the ass to
every real fucking fun guide for,
okay.
Or You have to listen to
me whistle constantly.
Hundred percent cutting
meat out of my life. 100%
I fucking hate listening to whistle.
Whistle for them.
That's terrible. That's terrible. No, no.
I'm already listen. No, I'm not having
any dairy tomorrow. I'm not. No,
no. That was terrible. That was
terrible. It was terrible. I know.
So
I, okay. That would be rough though.
That mean what you're proposing is
really difficult. That's terrible.
I would either I annoy the shit out
of you or you annoy the shit out of
everybody. That's a scenario and
I would miss that food for sure.
That's what's fucked up. But yeah, but
hearing you obviously sounds worse.
Waistline. Yeah. This is the thing
is it's not the, her whistle is bad.
It's that it would be
constant. It would be, yeah.
But even when I hear the world class
Whistler's I'm still like, well,
you'd knock that shit off,
please. Yeah, it's horrible.
I hate when people do it indoors,
you know,
like waiting in line at the
bank and the guy's like,
and you're like,
are you fucking serious right now?
He's asserting dominance. That's
what they're doing is, yes,
there is that territory is a psychological
reason, you know, 100% starting there.
This is my territory and
then has to fucking listen
to me whistle dish fucking I
hate them. I said, yeah, I think
you would rather fucking go vegan.
They listened to your cell phone.
That would be a real asshole.
Would rather listen to Christina
whistling all day every day
and who would rather go vegan
and listened to her waist. So
it's Kinda close proselytizing
Megan. Yeah, I'd be, I'd be
real annoying. Okay. Yeah.
One last one. Okay. This is, this is
more gross. Would you rather never floss?
You're done flossing. Some of you pigs
aren't doing it already. Okay. Yeah.
Or when you dump,
you're only allowed to wipe once.
Ooh,
wow. Wow. Heated debate in here.
Let the conversation just feels
like like a period piece. Yeah.
They're like, we're going to allow women
in the workforce and everyone's like,
what's going on?
That was such a sincere reaction.
They were like, whoa, lady, whoa.
I really can't take a big
stinky shit after I go.
I don't use toilet paper are flush the
toilet and get my hand that get in here
three roughly and then flush again.
84 five
he's nasty as hell. One
white dude. You'd be,
yeah, these are great questions. Okay.
Order order here,
here.
And this particular scenario we
are dealing with, but de Lis,
oh God dammit.
He's absolutely brilliant.
Would you rather and you will
entertain these thoughts?
Yes.
This triple d slept wife has,
boy,
no,
it is a thing.
The reason I choose a day less toilet
is because those are the every man's
scenario. Hold on, hold on. What you,
what you propose is so absurd and I
actually forgot what the other option is.
Okay.
What in the hell was the other?
No flossing.
Flossing
you are.
You are 51 50 if you choose one,
wipe over.
Not Philosophy again.
Are you out of your guide here?
Hold on.
I'm going to revise it in
the moment because I feel
there's a better option than
the flossing.
Would you rather have one wipe?
Yes or not wash your hands for a year.
Okay.
And that's a better,
would you rather
you could do that? You could
do that again would be, hey,
there's that fucking psycho
that wears gloves everywhere,
but it's better than being like,
Hey,
here's that guy that smells like fucking
piles of shit because he listens to a
podcast.
Yes,
a way around such a conundrum of the
one lab is to take a shower every time
you'll make a bowel movement.
That's it,
right?
That's the, that's the
work around. If you will,
a appeal denied.
That is not acceptable.
So
well, no, no, no. This is,
this is not the, so now listen,
if you do the one wipe, okay,
this is, you can wash your hands as
much as you like. Now that's the caveat.
So you can one meaningful
wipe goes a long way. Hey,
there are some shits I
take that only require one.
Get the fuck Outta here,
man.
What are you thinking Tom?
I mean if you don't wash
your hands for a year,
you're fucked in a lot of
ways. I mean, you really are.
Think about all the time.
Take it for granted. Oh,
that's not crazy. I'm
taking a shower like that.
You're just like
women and men of the GSA in the shower.
This,
this gentleman,
you bring up a valid point. What's the
point? What? What do you do to work? Okay.
You may put plastic baggies
over your hands in the shower.
Okay.
To to wash it like you ever have a cast
on your arm and you have to cover it.
You can do that. What? Sweetie?
I can't hear you. There's, there's,
that's what the Supreme Court would hear.
How are you going to wash your
asshole if you can't get your hands?
No, no, easily. Okay. I covered them in
play. I cover them in plastic baggies.
They're airtight because
it's so serious and
you are have a washcloth, which I'm
opposed to using in regular life,
but because of this thing I have to and I
wash cloth. My asshole. Easy peasy dude.
Yeah.
Fucking loofa that shit dude.
No plastic bags. No, no.
Yeah, that's true. You're suggesting
what a fucking would you rather,
I mean
this is Charlottesville all over again.
This is crazy.
Very divisive issue.
Why are you choosing hand washing,
hand washing or one wipe Dapa go forward.
Tom, what's your aunt's or final answer?
We need it.
Um,
I think one way.
Dot Gov one wipe.com.
I think I would definitely, I
would be the gnarly hands, dude.
I would just walk around
with unwashed hands.
I cannot be one wipe guy.
You gotta be kidding me?
There'd be times,
there would be times when you're like,
I just can't jump in the shower and you
could not, I could not go through life.
Like why you shrugging
like Eh, whatever. There,
there are many one white, but you can
shower after. So that's why I'm saying no.
What's that
number again?
He shut what?
What happens to demolition?
He scoops with that.
All right. This is getting, I haven't
seen in years. All right, look,
look at all the fucking, all right,
let's fucking take a vote. Yeah,
let's think about, okay. Who votes for
they know hand washing for a one year.
Go ahead.
Wow.
Who votes for one wipe dumps?
Do you hear that?
Sounded like that sounded like
more women did the one wipe down.
But I think as our shits are not as Nilan.
Uh, no, but look, it's
been, it's so fun, uh, that,
that you guys came out
tonight and we love, we have,
I tell people this all the time. We
love doing the podcast. It's the,
it's our favorite thing that we
do. So, uh, thank you very much.
You guys tell them we're
gonna go meet her. Oh yeah.
We're going to be out there.
Anybody that wants to meet
anybody who wants a picture,
I brought and uh,
you want to share it or whatever. We got
that. If not, we're fucking whatever.
We'll be out. I need to take a whiz so
gimme a second. Alright, we'll see you.
Thank you guys for coming out tonight.
Appreciate it.
You know that feeling when you have to go,
you have to
stretch your legs out.
Are you feeling you will get your
Dick off real off real quick.
It's all from, you know,
it wouldn't really matter.
You ever,
you ever busted one of those
kids?
Go and get different guys to just
in your mouth.
Can you map.